hi and welcome to serverless migration
station I'm Wesley from Google joined by
serverless Expedition host Martin to
help you modernize your apps running on
one of our serverless compute Platforms
in this and the next migration module
our little friend Porter will take you
on a journey to migrate from App engine
pull keys to Cloud Pub sub app engine
has push queues too right I'm familiar
with using push tasks to do extra work
alongside my apps yep and module 7
covers how to use push keys so check
that video in codelab to learn that
today we're focused on pull Q migration
that said this video won't feature any
migrating at all oh really Wes why not I
thought this was the serverless
migration video series uh what's up with
that
well you're always keeping me honest
Martin yes usually Porter does take
users from point A to point B but here
in module 18 we need to take a detour
first to reacquaint folks with app
engine pull tasks We'll add their use to
the module 1 sample app and then we can
migrate to Pub Sub in module 19. okay I
think I get it uh we're taking one of
our original python 2 apps adding app
engine pull tasks to it and then migrate
that app to Pub sub
yep you got it Martin in module one we
already migrated from App engine's web
app 2 framework to flask a popular
framework in the python Community while
web app 2 apps run on app engine flask
apps run on app engine and most other
hosting services so you can move off of
app engine if you ever need to pause now
to review the module 1 video in its
codelab to reacquaint yourself with that
migration because this module picks up
from where that leaves off
ah yes I do remember that migration uh
so what are we going to use pull cues
for in the sample app OS good question
the sample app currently registers all
visits to the website and displays the
most recent visits one way we can
enhance this app is by tracking visitors
and showing who visits our site the most
that makes sense so let's make our main
app do this counting after registering a
visit that's a really good idea but keep
in mind that this type of counting is
lower in priority serverless apps scale
better when they respond as quickly as
possible to the end user Ah that's right
the lower the latency the better also
this is about task queues so let's spawn
a push task to do this counting on the
side
yep that's a better idea you already
know that push tasks are pretty good
with lower party work that runs
alongside your app furthermore older app
engine apps must respond in less than a
minute and push tasks have an extended
10 minute deadline but push sets tend to
run very soon after they're created
meaning they still have fairly high
priority yeah you're right how do we
make something even lower in priority
than push tasks
well app engine task queue also has pull
tasks and I think that's a better fit
for this use case for each visit our app
can just drop a pull task in a work
queue then we can have a designated
worker running periodically grabbing all
the pull tests in the queue and batch
processing them all this worker can be a
Cron job or some other back-end service
okay I'm sold West let's use pull tasks
to be honest I haven't used app engine
pull tasks before and I actually even
forgot app engine had them can I get my
hands dirty and do it myself while
you're showing us on screen
absolutely grab your module 1 python 2
app if you did the code lab or clone the
repo or download the zip file if you
didn't pause here if you need to do that
module 1 is where we'll start if you
want to do this by hand with me now or
on your own time follow the module 18
codelab ready let's go to the computer
now and do this for all migrations we
want to start with a working app in this
case the module 1 sample whether you use
your code from doing the code lab or
copying it from the repo delete the lib
folder if you have one and run the PIP
install command to install the
third-party libraries into the lib
folder one benefit from upgrading to
Python 3 is that you no longer have to
do this self bundling in any case run
gcloud app deploy to upload to the cloud
the app should show the most recent
visits including the visit you just made
now that we've confirmed it works let's
start tracking visitors with pool tasks
in many migrations we start by modifying
configuration files but not this time
none of the existing configuration files
need to be touched they're fine as is
the other thing we need to do is create
the pull queue and that's done by adding
a new file named q.yaml with these three
lines
creating the file isn't enough we need
to explicitly deploy this file to the
cloud run gcloud app deployed but with
the q.yaml file name this doesn't deploy
the app itself it just modifies the
app's Q configuration moving on to
main.py Let's update the Imports and
constants at the top import the task
queue service and keep everything else
pull tasks have to be leased for a
certain amount of time so we arbitrarily
selected 1 000 tasks lease for an hour
so create constants for both the app has
always shown the top 10 most recent
visits while pool cues we're also going
to show the top 10 visitors so we might
as well create a constant for that for
lack of a better name I name the pull
queue pull queue and put those constants
before instantiating the pull queue and
flask app the visit data model doesn't
change as does querying for visits and
fetch visits the only change required is
in store visit in addition to
registering the visit add a pull task
with just the visitor's IP address so
the worker can increment the visitor
counter to track visitors we need a new
data model visitor counter tracks a
visitor by IP address as its string and
its counter as an integer a new function
fetch counts queries and Returns the top
10 visitors in descending order of most
visits the next new chunk of code to add
is for the worker to batch process all
tasks sitting in the pool queue the
first half of log visitors tracks all
the visitors in the queue and how many
times they visited in this batch
with this hash of visitors and visit
counts the second half either creates a
new visitor entry and data store or
increments the existing counts there
note the worker is called with a get
request to the slash log endpoint
finally the main Handler is updated so
it calls both fetch visits and fetch
counts then it sends the top visitors
plus the most recent visits to the web
template for rendering
the majority of the template stays the
same meaning rendering the most recent
visits newly added is the list of top
visitors and those are displayed at the
top as a table showing visitor and
corresponding visit counts and those are
all the changes to that use of pull
tasks to the module 1 sample app to
confirm your new module 18 app works
replace the lib folder by deleting the
old one and then running the PIP install
command to update all third-party
dependencies when all that's been done
run gcloud app deploy to deploy the app
you should now see a new table at the
top showing the top visitors followed by
the most recent visits now that looks
great but remember the visit you just
created isn't part of the overall
visitor count yet there's a task
awaiting execution in the pull queue if
you can visit your app a few more times
from different computers to get a good
number of tasks in there again you won't
see any change in the app other than the
most recent visits
now let's run the worker you can use a
browser but it's easiest to do a curl or
wget command in a terminal regardless of
which you use hit the slash log endpoint
and see the results showing how many
visitors were logged the next time you
visit the app the top visitors count
should be updated congrats you've now
added visitor accounts using pull tasks
thanks for the tutorial Wes since I've
only used push tasks a lot of this was
new to me can you point me to where in
the docs I can learn more about pull
tasks yeah the task you overview is
pretty useful and down below you'll also
find links to the docs for both push and
pull keys
cool I'll take a look now that I got
pull tasks usage in my app what's next
well now that we have pull tasks in the
app we'll migrate to Cloud Pub sub next
in module 19. if you want to read ahead
check out the links to the migration
page as well as the cloud Pub sub
documentation you can also do the module
19 codelab if you want to get a head
start or just check out the module 19
code sample in the repo and of course
the video and we look forward to having
you join us for module 19 and moving to
Cloud Pub sub this is Wesley on behalf
of Martin and Porter and we hope to see
you at that next migration station or on
another serverless Expedition soon happy
travels
[Music]